What it basically says is
that it is not possible to
construct a fair voting system.
The way that you can think about this
in very simple mathematical terms.
That I know that I think you'll like,
Michael,
is that all of these things
assume that everyone is
using exactly the same units.
Right, but if one of the agents is using
the metric system and someone else is
using the imperial system it turns
out you can't even compare the two.
There's absolutely no reason to believe,
that the values that each of these
individual agents are developing,
follow the same linear notion
of ordering of Q values.
And if that's not the case then
all of these things are basically
going to break.
Because all of them boil down to doing
what looks like some kind of addition or
averaging..
>> Or maxing.
>> Or maxing but maxing is just
kind of a weighted average.
Kind of an exponential averaging.
And so, you end up with a max that way.
Same thing with negotiated W learning
you're subtracting things and
taking mins.
In the end you're basically assuming
that I can compare your seven with my
seven and it means the same thing.
Why would your seven of my
seven mean the same thing?
So all of these have
that kind of problem.
And in fact there's a paper that
written by a student of mine,
that is a part of the readings,
that delve into this in more detail.
And we could spend a lot of time on it,
but actually the idea is very simple.
Which is really that once you
start thinking about goals, and
you think about these
individual modules or
individual options as trying to
accomplish different things.
You have to deal with the fact that
their goals may not be completely
compatible with one another.
And you have to come up with some
way of making them compatible.
And you can either assume that
compatibility by just pretending your
seven and my seven are the same.
Or you can say well there's some larger
goal you're trying to accomplish
that the arbitrator knows about.
The arbitrator is going to
make decisions based upon
whether it accomplishes that big goal.
In the predator prey case, for
example, the big goal might be
living long enough to reproduce.
And so I'm going to pick the subgoals
that allow me to live long enough
to reproduce.
>> I see, I think.
So there's a high level goal, and
then these subgoals that are chosen to
try to bring about the high level goal.
>> Right, and so it's the arbitrator
that has to decide what's going on.
So this is, this seems like
a kind of straightforward thing.
But I actually think it's kind of cool,
right.
That basically we went from actions
to abstract actions these options.
Those abstract actions
actually turn out to be.
Well at least one could
look at it this way.
Ways of accomplishing goals.
Once you have these ways of
accomplishing goals then suddenly
you realize well these goals don't
necessarily have to be
compatible with one another.
And so
I have to deal with that compatibility.
And so you move from an MDP
with primitive actions
to this larger notion
of balancing tradeoffs.
As you're trying to accomplish some
large goal for the entire system.
And in the end, they're still all
MDPs because they're SNDPs and
SNDPS are MDPs and in the end,
all of that reinforcement learning
stuff that we've been talking about
throughout the entire term still applies
>> And you've kind of brought together.
Generalization with multi agent.
You know type of thinking.
>> Yeah, so we got multi-agents, we got
single agents, we got multiple goals,
we got conflicting goals.
We've got abstraction and this gives
us scale and everything's wonderful.
>> Hallelujah.